rodman numero 14 no mas numero 15 in
faccia il 15 oggi con lui abbiamo deciso
di fare una cena natalizia me visto che
non passeremo il natale insieme abbiamo
pensato di trasformare questa giornata
un pochino nel nostro natale e famiglia
se e abbiamo deciso di organizzare una
cena spaccare un po sinonimo di
preparatevi al trash abbiamo questo
presupposto il frigo è a questo livello
questi spinaci stanno così tanto dalla
dentro che calcolate che mi hanno
aiutato a cucinare bolero le cose canti
qua dentro come cantare in una chiesa le
parole per questo per definire questo
frigo almeno un paio aggettivi anzi
cimitero putrefazione tristezza e
povertà gli valgono come parole ecco la
spesa per la cenetta di stasera
diciamo che l'ammontare di tutta questa
roba che vedete sta più o meno su quanto
proposto nel water ecco questo guarda
quanto magni con apple watch e la cosa
bella è che la mia famiglia se l'è
sturato tutto questo apple watch
credo che spazio per me qui dentro ha
cenato dopo ho chiesto su instagram in
realtà qualche giorno fa di farmi avere
delle idee devo dire che me ne sono
arrivate un sacco infatti ringrazio le
persone che mi seguono su instagram e
soprattutto mi si filano e soprattutto
si accontenta per festa sfilata e tra
queste vorrei dirvi quelle che poi sono
state selezionate per il menu di stasera
allora abbiamo delle caramelle di uova
di quaglia crostini di salmone perché ho
capito che il salmone per forza ci deve
stare me l'avete detto tutti mozzarella
pane gorgonzola questo come antipasto
poi com'è prima ho pensato di gustare
lasagna che più veloce quindi lasagna
all'amatriciana e lasagna funghi e
tartufo abbiamo un rus tacchino ripieno
che vi farò vedere dopo e infine
panettone e mascarpone questo annunciano
proprio pensato è un'apocalisse di
kinder sinonimo di facevo prima ordine
un catering da cracco lo sembrava che tu
quattro ore di masterchef non vi ho
detto la cosa più importante ossia che
stasera a tutti gli ospiti devono venire
mascherati tema natale e io so già che
alcuni dei miei parenti stanno veramente
dando il meglio di loro
ok nuovo parto con la cosa che non mi
dovevi fare il rosta quito rotta chi no
mamma mia questo cosa c'entra il 13
poncho più bene lo sapevo che avrei
versato tutta la quale funghi per terra
lo sapevo e anche sul mio pene ve lo
ricordate di comprare il doppio delle
cose perché metà finiscono per terra
vabbè era da un po che non passavo il
mocio in cucina valle ok abbiamo le
cipolle caramellate che devono
raffreddarsi da mettere qua e poi da
mettere te
parlano poi abbiamo i funghi e nel
frattempo faccio andare la matriciana
per le tue lasagne e adesso non lo so
devo dire poco ma che fai sta facendo st
testa qua la corona a quella è la corona
per premiare la migliore maschera di
stasera
guardate che stile che a questo ragazzo
notti rosa ma sei sicuro che non sempre
super calibrati di stick e spiritoso
nemmeno un cordino ok una piccola rubato
uno mi sono appena reso conto di essere
in terribile tardo quindi non posso
aspettare che questa quasi
si raffreddi e dovrò morire ustionato
massaggiandola dentro perché se no stop
dopo quello che dovrà cucinare credo tre
ore e mezza 4 all'interno del forno non
si preparerà mai non sono state
incolleranno
a
ahia ahia
ai conti è quasi piacevole oh sì
sì che piacere senti bolcato di cipolle
con il freddo del del vitello e comunque
posso dire una cosa questo può essere
peso ci fossero k accesa un occhio a smr
perché fa
rumore pazzesco una leggera presa male
per il pollo non era spennella ma cosa
c'è in questa mia lettera e
l'imbottitura è quella che sinceramente
mi sembra tanta
ora non voglio fare una battuta ma non
so quanta roba possa ospitare ragazzi
non avete idea di entrata cioè un'annata
aeroporto parte bisogna chiuderlo
[Musica]
chiedono chi no c'è proprio utilizzare
degli stuzzicadenti città ieri voci con
maniglioni oggi usa polli non usare una
colla a caldo anche nel loro con tutta
la classe
se potessi lo farei con quanto del
forchetta calcolare non è venuto in
mente di doverlo fare perché pensavo
tipo alle cene di natale dei film ti
dicono queste cose nei film 14 integra
su al forno modo il giorno non vinciamo
niente solo per dimenticare il progetto
almeno quattro ore con ragazzi e ragazze
ho fatto stop vestito di pancetta da
mummia egizia tutankhamon e niente mollo
informerò e credo che andrà lì per per
sempre per il resto ai suoi giorni a
stare dentro un piccolo spoiler alla
fine c'è stato 5 ore sta battola dentro
cinque ore da notare il fatto che gli ho
messo anche e cosa se si vedono
avete presente le scarpette quelle che
si vedono nei film fatto di alluminio
eccole lì sono arrivati rinforzi mentre
stavo facendo le lasagne a funghi e
tartufo e tartufo e besciamella sono
andati rinforzi di cugine che lavano
grande grande rosario grande e altra
cugina che aiutano che sta totti
sono state creando dei bellissimi omini
di neve e lattosio anno le conosce
ascoltano la musica ben gurini allora
mentre facciamo andare o di non se ne va
bene in che modo possiamo riempire
questo spazio
perché se fa perché gelesi festa pacco
regalo che [ __ ] bellissima bellissima
vado a lavorare e che bello ok mentre
maicon con zona siamo 40 minuti al
servizio vuole sentire si chef perfetto
senti che abbiamo fatto le lasagne di
tempo perfetto guarda bisogna punire
questo questo e questo ottimo da notti
sbrighiamoci stanno per arrivare le
persone ancora in alto mare in alto mare
in alto mare e cosa fa sentire allora
sono già arrivati alle persone ma noi li
ignoriamo nel frattempo aspettiamo che
queste caramelline non so se vedete
sembrava lette di pollo ma sono le
caramelline di uovo di quaglia
scusate ragazzi scusate
e non aggiungo altro per uscendo male
rovinosa per riprendere l'entrata
scenica passato
questi sono enrico e gianmarco che
ultimamente stanno lavorando entrambi
con me se non sapete da cosa sono
vestiti voi praticamente non avete mai
conosciuto il natale in realtà ne
sentirà primi mamma ho perso l'aereo
se venissi geniale si sia fatto la casa
pazzesca ma gabriele amato grazi
[Applauso]
scusami come non è vestito compleanno
conduce su ti prego fai qualcosa
figlio mio la santità ragazzi e cosa sta
invece questa sera venendo nella
spazzatura ma state cercando qualcosa
che vi siete persi ma che stai
scherzando per la cosa è loretto killers
the ravanando nella monnezza appetiti in
piedi ti prego che tu faccia il tuo show
ed ha combinato il messia
[Risate]
i tre più votati di stasera solo devo
chiedervi scusa perché non vi ho fatto
vedere il roast tacchino le lasagne le
parti apple arriva ecco un messaggio
perdonatemi da parte di mia cugina che
ha fatto delle foto tutte le maschere
vele metto subito così in
sovrimpressione mettete pausa allora in
alto abbiamo il mio fratello e mio
cugino vestiti dai ladri di mamma ho
perso l'aereo poi c'è mio fratello con
mio cugino vestiti da padre maronno è il
messia io e luigi poi abbiamo i sovrani
del natale mio fratello e la ragazza mia
cugina vestita da pacco regalo ma allo
stesso tempo questo qui è un dilemma
originale insieme al ragazzo vestito da
candy kane e infine mia cugina vestita
da dopo poi l'altra mia cugina da elfo e
infine emanuela da rudolf ma torniamo
alla premiazione per il 3 o la regina
delle pale valentina abbiamo anche
gianmarco errico gabriele un applauso
questi
il vincitore è il natale vince nel 2018
è da ballan
la coppia mar venerdi 14 10 ma che
chiusa